so long-term plan you want to build a
house i want to build a house you want
your own house
yeah not a student room your uncle then
i've still not seen this land
that's really nice that's your dream
right to have your own home here
so why don't we call your uncle yeah go
have a look at the land
the land oh yeah let's go left house
stay off the top of that height
yeah that's what i'm on about i can
build it for so cheap i've got the land
for free
yeah i'm gonna build it refinance it
then pull all my money out so
i can end up basically on normal nobody
down
self-built yeah so it's really really
nice so
i'm going to build a planning to build a
two-story house here overlooking that
lake
and then it's really nice so you're
gonna you okay so right now it's in your
uncle's name we've just spoke to him
and he's confirmed he's happy to give it
to you yes basically when i build it
and refinance it i'm gonna follow my
money do you think
that you would get planning to build
here yeah i don't see why not
because all the other houses up there
two story houses we've got planning
there's two
so don't see why not would it be like
similar to these houses here yeah
hey it'd be nice pav
there's no way he's gonna get planning
to build on this on this side
i mean literally we're right on the top
of the hill if he built here
he'd be breaking skyline views
there's no access at all there's a a
road that's shared by multiple people
and uh it's just not gonna happen
it's like a pipe dream building here
so his uncle has given him the land sure
but he's about to build should i tell
him or what shall i wait till i get back
take him one tell him now yeah yeah
dave pat be honest
jamaica i would love it man if i can put
like a two-story house worth thinking
about maybe
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah get the leg few
there it's really good
the only concern i have with this land
getting the relevant permissions to do
what you want to do here
if you get the relevant permissions i
think it's awesome
i reckon you could build cheap i
actually never looked into the planning
i could shift to this land a few years
ago what do you think of
the sky breaking the skyline views
how will they how the council what do
you mean by scaling for you well right
now we're on the top of
the hill yeah so
so if we built here i know you're
talking about the other houses
yeah but all the other houses yeah
yeah yeah but but where are they on top
of the hill
no no they're all low down aren't they
so what are you
you're trying to see if i built here
it's it'll be really cool
to be like but all the people drive
down below is it's gonna break the
skyline view
i'm not an expert when it comes to
planning permission in ireland and
skyline views but i'm just
if you had a house here where would you
park your car over there what we'd have
to do is who owns the road
there's quite a few people so you'd have
to get permission to to use the road i
don't know where you're gonna park i
don't know if you get permission to
drive the road you'd have to
whoever owns the road you have to get
permission i don't think it's as
straightforward as just being like oh
i've got a piece of land i can just
build a house there i think
before i get too excited i would speak
to the council
out of 10 what do you think in terms of
how beautiful it would be i think it's a
10.
in terms of how likely
i'd say probably a 0.1 why don't we just
speak to the council direct
and just say i think you've got this in
your head that you want to build here is
my
yeah okay i'll be opening the options
but it's not
okay well don't be disappointed let's
just go in
yeah okay well so
we just spoke into planning and it's
looking for david
like if mr o'sullivan has a house here
and mr mcgregor has a house here and mr
murphy has a house here
uh mr david echols cannot have a house
here
breaking skyline views
that's disappointing that's because
that's the only site that i've got for
free
and i always thought i could build there
someday so why don't we find more sites
with planning maybe in better positions
land is cheap land is cheap but i don't
think we'll get a site here
there is no sites you don't want to live
in a student house
no you don't want to buy a piece of land
without planning with sheep around
everywhere on the skyline view
there must be an in between somewhere in
the middle that's
lake so this piece of land here
which is for sale how far is that from
here
where is it it's about
five minutes from here okay
well this has got planning permission
0.75 acres with function for a four
bedroom detached house
full planning look at it okay
35 000 pounds
that's yours you're in ireland okay well
what's that
what does that work in pounds uh there's
less isn't it
if that was even better so thirty
thousand pounds
sorry thirty thousand pounds yeah yeah
full planning permission
nice sight that'll be much better so
recall the agent
um you can't do but to be honest i don't
even think we need to call the agent to
book an appointment it's a piece of land
we can just
if you know where it is that would be
much better
than about getting a free piece of land
and then trying to build on it when you
can't build on it
could be the good time for david to
build his house that's quite a big sense
it is a massive site i just feel so good
to be home doesn't it
well this isn't home for me but i know
you i i can see why you like it here
thanks i love it
i love it these houses that are just
like just
oh that's what it does here it's really
really nice i know
so because look at all these how much
would this how much of this house would
be to just buy
150 thousand that is cheap but we're
like
i guess we're in the republic of ireland
aren't we yeah but oh
man it is i can see why you like it
this is nice isn't it i think it is it
smells like
cow poop so this is the site
this is the site yeah here's the here's
what i want to know
how much is that house worth that hosts
probably 150 160. well let me find out
did you know that property power does
have so what's the post go to this place
uh my location got it there is no poor
school oh they're not
looks like a solid piece of land nice
area planning permission already
let's see how much we can get this land
for i'm going to phone the agent
how would you feel about a house here i
would like it
this is nice here well we'll get
planning permission over here so house
actually looks really nice
hi there i'm just thinking about the
piece of land that you've got for sale
yep which one so it's drum freeze
a couple of questions firstly would be
if we built that four bed house that's
got planning permission do you know how
much the
the end value would be of the property
yeah
[Applause]
if you did a good job on it probably
maybe
250 275 something like that you're
nearly only a winner just with a
well-built house in the first place you
know
this actually could work because
somebody's trying to buy it he used to
be there i'm not sure about it no the
sign is yeah i'm
actually standing at the sign right now
i need to get a quote from my builders
to see how much it would actually cost
to build
to work out if it's viable this could
work
i i was often told they're not worth it
but
if he's right and it would be worth 275
at the end of it if you could buy this
for 30 grand
and build a house for 120 that means
you're 150 you're all in yeah and then
the end value was 250
yeah i don't know if that would be the
case you'd definitely be able to raise
the finance even from a private investor
based on the figures that he said i
would buy it oh my god
i don't know what to say 1900
square foot yeah four and it's a four
bed
over one and a half stories do you think
that i'm in cloud cooking land
thinking like 250 275 for for a four bed
in that area
uh your projects would be worth that but
more you know no but it certainly
wouldn't be far
ballpark away thank you so much brian
speak to you on monday cheerio bye
that's good news he's basically said
that 275 is not unrealistic for a full
bed in that area
okay he's going to drive by he's going
to give us more restaurant oh i think we
should pay him
200 quid to get an official evaluation
but i think that it's looking like it
goes
that's sexy really really we need to
find out how much it would cost to build
it my even in england that will cost me
150 grand in england i reckon
it's gonna be a lot cheaper here so
i don't have the actual plan but it's
i would need to really get the plan but
looking at it it goes down
over and kind of back up this field it's
a 1900 square foot house
three must come in here at an angle
and i'll show when it i suppose yeah
when you clear your phone it's
what's he saying he reckons it's the
side of the wire
smell that yeah
[Music]
[Music]
look at the pictures and the pictures
pictures are over there
look hi
what what would you think the picture is
of that piece of land
the sign is on that piece of land but
then
[Applause]
i did think it sounded cheap for 35
grand
that's average that piece of land
oh jeez what's disappointing i don't
know
the pictures are actually off the site
you know what dude i don't think
personally i don't think you should even
try and build a house right now
i really don't i can't believe it i just
accidentally paid
30 000 pound for a river
i i really want to build my own property
i just can't afford it
at the moment so i think tomorrow the
best strategy for
me would be to go and look for a lease
option agreement
so should we go make some courses and
agents yeah let's do it
so what did just say we're looking to
i'm looking to buy a house but i can't
afford it
so i want to rent somewhere which i can
call home but with a view to own and get
down the line so i'm going to do rent to
own
if you've got any properties or
landlords or sellers
they'll be open to an arrangement like
that and then just be silent don't talk
too much
you shouldn't talk you shouldn't that
took me about 20 seconds that's the max
that easy yeah i'm actually looking for
a property
to rent i actually haven't got a deposit
so i'm looking for a property to rent
what you said to him and she said i'm
looking for a property to rent
but i have a deposit what he'll think
you mean is he'll think you mean you
don't have
a month's upfront rent deposit and then
he'll immediately be thinking
no and then you've lost we've only got
how many agents are in this whole area
three well we can't afford that so you
need to say i'm looking for a property
to buy
i want to i want someone i can call home
i don't have a deposit to buy somewhere
just yet
so i need to rent but i want to rent to
own
have you got any landlords i'll be open
to do a rent to earn okay i'm glad the
signal cut
where should we go to make these calls
okay
no problem thanks very much keepers were
quite helpful actually he says i don't
really understand how that works i don't
know what that is
but it was really friendly recommended
you speak to her
that's another one yeah i think we're
going to get somewhere just by
the thing is in ireland they're so
friendly and helpful and open-minded
and this does legally work i've been
looked into it
these options agreements work so if we
could buy a house now yeah for you to
live in
pay for it later but in the meantime pay
like a peppercorn rent that's perfect
take care of the maintenance
then that's going to be better than
living in there i never thought this
could work it's going to be better than
living with students
in a room with your girlfriend
no problem thank you for your help so
the estate agent said we only deal with
sales you can't rent it to buy it
the latin agent said we only deal with
lettings you can't ever buy it so we
need to just find somebody else that's a
bit
more fluid i can't believe they were
just like we have
no houses in the whole of what's it
called bucanna bonkrana bonkrana
no houses in bon kwana the rental here
is
because people can't afford to buy they
come on around and there's no houses to
rent
crazy so it's like we're a letting agent
in bonkrana but we have no houses to let
granny
okay you must be busy i see what you
mean about no work out here
geez because they can't afford to buy
you can one day around
okay call the next person one for sales
two for sales
they do both though that's a good sign i
can't say we don't do sales or we don't
do that
but they'll say you're true to the
scenes are they like english people here
or not yeah do you wanna
maybe yeah yeah this is my last story
who is it
hello my name's samuel uh just a quick
call i'm looking for
a property i'm looking for somewhere
that i can rent
but with an option to buy it down the
line so i can save up for my deposit i
don't know if that's
something you guys would consider but i
want someone i can call home
that i can rent but i haven't got like a
full deposit to actually go ahead and
buy somewhere just yet
i mean obviously i'd only need one uh
one landlord
to agree to it and i'm sure i could make
it quite attractive because i really
want
somewhere that i can call home you know
so i've not got the fear of being kicked
out or something i can do maybe
home improvements cheers bye
very interesting that's the first agent
that does both
so yeah sales and lettings yeah and they
were like we've never done it before but
we'll call our
landlords and see if they're up for it
you're so good at this
so lease option agreement rent to buy
one agent that's open to it are there
any more agents in the area
one more agent all right let's find him
hello uh my name is david
i'm just wondering have you got any
properties to rent you know
we have nothing on our books at the
moment but i can take it
and i can contact you whenever something
comes up no we don't have anything at
the moment
oh god so there's no houses for sale at
all
um they are the most up-to-date for this
general area
okay no houses that's what i said you
cannot
so the agents are really open to do
business but there's just no houses at
all for sale
there's not one house for seeing waffle
needed right in that case
do you know anyone that owns any houses
down here
i do
family friends who
i actually have an uncle okay not the
uncle that owns the land
no a different girl on the other side of
the [ __ ]
house is that the one we drove past yeah
what is it empty at the moment is it
i think there might be a tenant but that
property is
basically it wasn't on the property for
years so it could be a buy
town center because they moved the
tenant out very easily
so could you move in that by him a small
rant with an option to bite down the
line i would love to move on there
that's right isn't your uncle living in
america
yeah so he'll be in bed right now
because the time is now
half past 10 in the morning and he'll be
in the middle of the night
let's go inside drop him an email
anybody else that owns any houses i can
make a few calls
trying to find a lease option agreement
in david's area it's not easy because
there's just
hardly any houses and there's nothing
for sale
there's nothing for let it's not that
people are close-minded to the idea
people are very open-minded over here so
i said to david who do you know that
just
owns a house so where are we going now
going to my uncle's house and he owns a
house
and you know he's open side here so
we've got to
put a few in on the property so tenants
are in there at the moment
we'll just look around have a
conversation see what happens so just
viewed the house
sea views it is nice man that is really
nice
uncle owns the house yes yeah at the
moment so we can't film inside yeah
but should we chat with you uncle see
what we can do
you guys live there i love to live there
so a really nice house that is nice
close to your house having a good
conversation with
david i did a good conversation with
david yeah
oh yes there he is so
we did kind of come to an agreement okay
that
we agreed to buy the house in five years
time
right for two hundred thousand okay so
in the meantime then we're going to rent
it after
yeah yeah so that's what we're doing so
that's great
excellent well i hope it works out and i
think um
yeah where do you live do you live in
ireland
i'm in chicago right now oh you're in
chicago
oh wow great well i'm sure he'll i'm
sure he'll take good care of it
all right excellent well hey real good
to meet you anyway and uh all the best
with the with the venture with the
uh the lease option agreement
good to meet you thanks
all right speak later speak to it
bye-bye thank you bye-bye
[Music]
so basically in a year's time i'll pay a
small rent
so i've actually got the first year free
and then how much rent will you pay
after that
400 euro months so that's peanuts and
then in the next year you'll just like
make sure the property's okay i fixed it
up a little bit that's what
i want to do the refurb for the first
year so bring the house up the standard
i've been able to get
painting and then 400 euro months right
after that there it's my
property nice creative deal well done
well done really really happy with us
awesome
in ireland in ireland i didn't think you
could work this is in a hard time
oh nice so this is a lot better than
buying a property
yeah it is so free for the first year
yesterday round three
yeah 400 euros
[Music]
i am now typing up the heads of terms
for david's lease option agreement to
show his uncle
it's funny because he didn't think these
option agreements were even allowed in
ireland we're in the republic of ireland
uh but it does work so
he's doing really well this is the kind
of stuff that goes normally on soon
contracts so i got here seven days ago
david had nothing
now he's got two no money down deals one
rent remember one lease option agreement
he's made 10 000 pounds from packaging
and selling deals
he's got project management things lined
up oh yeah
echoes of states ready to make some
money a business set up
he wants he just found some more
opportunities as well and development
sites
two more two yeah he wants me to stay a
bit longer and try and package them and
don't venture them but i need to go
because my wife is about to have a baby
so david
i'm gonna shoot i love you bro
um
no how bad
like it's quite it feels like it
definitely feels like contractions i
mean
i don't know i don't know but
i think it's doing something i'll be
back
in two hours
i'll be back in two i'll be back in two
hours
two hours oh my goodness she's having
contractions
i left at the right time
okay you're not gonna make it
oh my goodness it's david's girlfriend
how are you how you feeling
are you on your way to meet david right
now you are gonna he's a new person
you're gonna love him hey
congratulations well done
[Music]
you're just chilled out
hey what's up we have just had our baby
jessica grace
it's now seven weeks since the financial
freedom challenge what did you think
when i left you nine months pregnant
i was worried because the baby could
come any time i just about got back in
time for her
and also here you go um david
not only did he become financially free
in seven days
but he came round our house to visit
thank you so much so david it's now been
seven weeks since the challenge
thank you this is beautiful tell us
david um
what's happened since the financial
freedom challenge things have really
taken off
i've made money uh rent to rent it's
fully left
fully lit sorry baby yeah i've got
police option agreements
i have got the made money and i started
my own estate agent
oh dude so this is seven weeks later
you've also just you do you're doing
deals what happened just on monday
i saw the did for two and a half
thousand party just started
on monday so guys we're gonna do a full
interview me and david
winners on a wednesday it's coming out
tomorrow where we're gonna talk about
exactly what happened what he did in the
week
subscribe to the channel also david
should they join the crash course
definitely that's where it all started
one point you know it's literally
notes join at the property investors
crash course below i'll leave a link in
the description
what subscribe you can subscribe right
here so that you can see his full
winners on a wednesday and i look
forward to seeing you guys
next time bro good job